well are reviewed michael bay's six
underground it's only fair I review
Richard Jewell perfectly balanced his
old thing should be you know the drill
[Music]
Richard Jewell was a fan of snap earlier
doesn't whatever so Richard jewels
directed by Clint Eastwood it's a true
story of Richard Jewell during the
Olympics in 1996 in Atlanta there was a
bombing and there was a hero that found
the bomb took action saved a lot of
lives that was Richard Jewell after the
bombing incident he was a hero and then
he was the FBI's prime suspect and the
press found out he was a suspect and
then ran with the story and then that's
when it gets shitty for this is the true
story of that guy now first of all Clint
Eastwood I'm 50/50 on he's either hit or
miss with me this is one of the hits
I liked Richard Jewell I really enjoyed
it I'm glad you get to see Richard
Jewell side of it but also I liked
everyone in the movie first of all Paul
Walter Hauser as Richard Jewell I don't
know what Paul Walter Hauser's like I
don't really know what Richard Jewell is
like but he so naturally conveys this
persona of this person who's just he's a
nice dude he's a nice guy who wants to
do good he wants to do the best he can I
have met and known people like him and
they are so that guy that I gotta say
the actor is either like that or he's
getting an Oscar
we good luck tell me he's British is he
British in real life oh wow wouldn't it
be the best I got a call perfect casting
on this one but it's also him and Sam
Rockwell they're dynamic they work
really well together Sam Rockwell plays
the lawyer that it gets as I all right
I'll help you out I have history you
know so he wants to help this guy out
but Richard Jewell is just he's so
willing to help the FBI hang him but he
doesn't realize he's like well I just
want to cooperate with law enforcement I
want to cooperate with the US government
that's what a good citizen does Sam
Rockwell's like stop stop talking I'll
do the talking stop it it's actually
quite amusing to see the dynamic between
those two I don't mind saying it makes
the movie for me also Kathy Bates is
Richard Jules mom I thought she was
really good Jon Hamm is the lead FBI
agent coming after him Olivia Wilde was
really good it's funny she has the most
personality in the movie but her
personality is very abrasive and I'm
like was she was the person actually
like that then you hear they got it
wrong there was some controversy
surrounding that possible misinformation
in the movie someone gives her
information she's like okay let's have
sex kind of reminds me of James Cameron
and tight
makino there was that guy in Titanic and
he shot somebody and then he shoots
himself in the head but that was a named
person who worked on the Titanic so the
family was really pissed they're like
nothing says he killed somebody and then
killed himself that that's where's that
saw James Cameron say if there's
something he could change in Titanic
that would be it you want to get it
right if you're making a biopic but when
you're making a biopic about someone who
got it wrong you want to get it right I
do find it interesting that that's the
thing people are pissed about because
the FBI agents do some really shady [ __ ]
in this movie it's like okay so no one's
pissed about that does that mean that
actually happened did they try to trick
Richard Jewell into signing a confession
did they try to trick him into that
phone call and recording the phone call
like did that happen there is a point in
this movie where I felt like the movie I
was like okay now you feel a little long
it's true you could have trimmed a
little bit off this movie but I didn't
regret it's not like I walked out going
oh it was so long I really enjoyed it
and I felt like it was a very timely
message it's good that we're seeing the
story of the past but also it points to
us in the present I mean the media
before they run a story like this they
have to know that they're going to drag
someone so they better be sure and it's
something I grew up knowing that the
media just knew but more and more lately
that seems to be less of a priority and
this isn't a review on the media so I'll
keep this brief but I'm not an analyst
on it this is just my perspective but
what I have noticed is when people see
clips of stories and news videos they
probably watch the YouTube version of it
or watched it on Twitter point is likes
retweets views so online video
entertainment and news just kind of
became indistinguishable from each other
which means the news media is chasing
cliques like the rest of entertainment
on YouTube I just think that's playing a
very dangerous game when your job is to
inform the public but a big part of your
circulation and viral presence comes
from operating on YouTube a website that
lends itself to okay get people to click
slay with fire but also Richard Jewell
is an important message to us the people
who's also back in 1996 the news was the
one with that power they were Superman
they had the power and the
responsibility that power being the
power of information and voice the news
could and can end a career or make a
life much harder for someone based on
the story they put out there they could
be Superman or home lander hope they
were Superman but then social media and
now we all have that superpower the
Richard Jewell thing we have the power
to do that to people
point the finger
online we can send a mob people's way we
have the power now to be Superman or
homeland er that is a lot of power and
I'm just saying homeland er thinks he's
Superman it is I like that I like when I
walk out of a movie and I go okay how
can it apply to today oh wow it totally
does a story of the past that is echoed
in the president is obviously if I'm
thinking about if this had happened
today I don't know that Richard Jewell
would have even survived the social
media storm so I'm glad we got to see a
well acted well-executed personal story
of someone behind this kind of well
we'll call it a shitstorm I was gonna
say Richard Jewell is worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray
all right so Richard Jewell have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]